lo que estamos viendo es uno de los
órganos más increíbles en tu cuerpo es
el corazón humano se muestra con todos
sus vasos y puedes ver todos los vasos
entrando y saliendo pero el corazón en
su centro es una bomba y está bomba es
la razón por la que le llamamos el
órgano que más trabaja en nuestro cuerpo
porque empieza a bombear sangre desde el
momento en que eres un pequeño feto tal
vez sobre las ocho semanas de edad y
durante toda la vida hasta el momento en
que mueres así que creo que es muy
interesante profundizar en el estudio de
este órgano pero es un poco difícil si
solo observamos el exterior así que lo
que hice fue dibujar cómo se ve en el
interior déjame mostrarte lo y
seguiremos el camino de la sangre al
corazón en este diagrama empezaremos con
una pequeña imagen en la esquina
digamos que aquí tenemos una persona
su cara este es su cuello por acá
tenemos los brazos y tiene en medio de
su pecho su corazón
entonces el objetivo es asegurarnos de
que ante todo la sangre de todas partes
de su cuerpo incluyendo sus piernas
pueda regresar al corazón y después sea
bombeada de nuevo al cuerpo entonces la
sangre viene de este brazo y se vierte
en el corazón
pasa lo mismo del otro lado y también va
a venir de su cabeza las tres fuentes
los dos brazos y la cabeza se van a unir
en una gran vena y esa gran vena dará
salida en la parte superior del corazón
y de manera separada
tienes venas de las piernas que se
juntan con las venas del vientre que
entran por otra apertura y es así como
la sangre regresa al corazón y cada vez
que mencionó la palabra pena quiero
asegurarme de que pienses en la sangre
que va hacia el corazón
ahora la sangre va hacia el corazón y
después este la bombea es decir que
tiene que salir de él tiene que alejarse
del corazón para eso sirven las cortas
las aortas tienen un pequeño arco de
esta forma que llamamos el arco aórtico
y envía un vaso al brazo un vaso hacia
arriba otro vaso está acá y este arco de
alguna forma baja y baja y baja y baja y
se separa así todo esto es una versión
simplificada pero como puedes ver
definitivamente hay algunas semejanzas
en cómo están configuradas las venas y
las arterias y las arterias cada vez que
mencionó la palabra arteria quiero
asegurarme de que pienses en la sangre
que sale del corazón ahora sí vamos el
diagrama grande podemos ver que la
sangre entra de este modo y también de
este modo y llega al mismo lugar la
sangre llega a la aurícula derecha
este es el nombre de la cámara donde
termina la sangre y la sangre entra a la
aurícula derecha desde un vaso gigante
llamado vena cava superior
esta es una vena por supuesto que trae
sangre al corazón y por lo tanto por acá
abajo tenemos la vena cava inferior la
sangre fluye en estas dos direcciones
una vez que la sangre está en la
aurícula derecha baja al ventrículo
derecho
este es el ventrículo derecho esta es la
segunda cámara del corazón la sangre
llega a él pasando por una válvula
básicamente esta válvula y todas las
válvulas del corazón están ahí para
mover la sangre en la dirección correcta
así que nunca se regresa esta válvula se
llama válvula tricúspide se llama así
porque esencialmente son tres pequeñas
balbás o aletas es por eso que tiene el
prefijo tree sé que aquí sólo vemos dos
de ellas en mi dibujo esto es porque mi
dibujo no es perfecto y es difícil
mostrar un aval va saliendo de nosotros
pero podemos imaginarla entonces la
sangre entra al ventrículo derecho
y ahora a dónde se dirige bueno después
de eso seguirá su camino hacia este vaso
y se va a separar pero antes de llegar
allá tiene que pasar por otra válvula
esta es la válvula pulmonar y te da una
pista hacia dónde se dirigen las cosas a
continuación la palabra pulmonar se
refiere al pulmón así que este es mi
pulmón izquierdo y éste es mi pulmón
derecho y estos pasos que vamos a
adivinar cómo se llaman esta es mi
arteria pulmonar izquierda si es la
izquierda hice énfasis justo allí para
asegurarme de que tú lo asimile es
porque está llevando sangre lejos del
corazón y esta otra es mi arteria
pulmonar derecha
ahora la sangre llega a mis pulmones
estos son los pulmones que de alguna
manera están dentro de mi tórax donde se
encuentra mi corazón así que la sangre
entra a mis pulmones y recuerda esta
sangre es azul porque es azul bueno es
azul porque no tiene mucho oxígeno así
que una cosa que la sangre necesita
recoger es oxígeno esto es lo que los
pulmones me van a ayudar a recoger y
escribiré todos como anotación para el
oxígeno y también debemos recordar que
es azul porque está llena de dióxido de
carbono está llena de residuos ya que
viene del cuerpo cierto nuestro cuerpo
produce mucho dióxido de carbono y trata
de deshacerse de él así que los pulmones
nos deshacemos del dióxido de carbono y
recogemos oxígeno es por ello que cambio
de un vaso color azul a un vaso color
rojo ahora la sangre regresa por aquí y
por acá y se vierte en
la cámara y cómo se llama bueno estás
aurícula izquierda
al igual que la aurícula derecha tenemos
una izquierda después la sangre baja y
podemos adivinar a nuestro ventrículo
izquierdo de igual manera que cuando
pasamos de la aurícula derecha al
ventrículo derecho ahora pasamos de la
aurícula izquierda al ventrículo
izquierdo y después pasamos por una
válvula aquí esta válvula se llama la
válvula mitral y por supuesto su trabajo
es asegurarse de que la sangre no se
regrese por accidente del ventrículo
izquierdo a la aurícula izquierda quiere
asegurarse de que la sangre fluya hacia
adelante por último tenemos otra válvula
por la que pasa la sangre que escribiré
por acá y se llama la válvula aórtica y
la válvula aórtica va a ser la que
divide este ventrículo izquierdo de este
vaso gigante del que hablamos hace rato
por supuesto esta es la ahora
ahora la sangre sale de la aorta al
resto del cuerpo
puedes ver como la sangre fluye del
cuerpo a las cuatro cámaras primero
entra a la aurícula derecha
esta es la cámara número 1 después va al
ventrículo derecho
esta es la cámara número 2 va a los
pulmones y regresa a la aurícula
izquierda
esta es la cámara número 3 y por último
al ventrículo izquierdo
es decir la cámara número 4
y esto pasa cada momento de cada día
cada vez que escuches tu corazón latir
está ocurriendo este proceso